what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and this morning we have a lot of really
exciting news for Marvel fans for those
waiting for Avengers Kang Dynasty we
have some big updates today also some
updates about Jonathan Majors that are
actually good this time plus if you
haven't heard there is some really cool
Spider-Man news that Disney just
announced this morning plus Elizabeth
Olsen has commented on her potential
return to the MCU in a recent interview
where she states that she is well let's
say hopeful so a lot to talk about today
so if you love Marvel be sure to
subscribe to the channel also leave a
comment because that enters you in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items and
some DC items a winner is picked at the
end of each month so first things first
let's hit you with that awesome
Spider-Man news five Spider-Man movies
are making their way to Disney plus
really soon tomorrow actually April 21st
Disney plus officially announced this on
Twitter from their official Twitter page
stating Spider-Man arrives tomorrow
April 21st on Disney plus and like I
said they announced five different
Spider-Man movies starting with Toby
Maguire's very first Spider-Man film
Spider-Man 2 Spider-Man 3 then heading
over to The Amazing Spider-Man the first
one and then Spider-Man homecoming so
for the Spider-Man fans you can now
watch these on Disney plus no word yet
about The Amazing Spider-Man 2 or
Spider-Man far from home or no way home
as a lot of people know Marvel Studios
doesn't have the streaming rights to
Spider-Man so we'll have to be a little
bit more patient waiting for The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 Spider-Man far from home
and Spider-Man no way home but in the
meantime you can watch these other five
Spider-Man movies on Disney plus now
moving over to the Kang Dynasty and
right now this is kind of controversial
given all of the stuff that is going on
right now with Jonathan Majors if you
haven't been keeping up Jonathan Majors
not too long ago was arrested and he was
charged with abusing his girlfriend he
apparently a assaulted her broke one of
her fingers caused a cut behind her ear
however him and his lawyer immediately
came out with a statement stating he was
innocent and was actually the victim in
this situation and they came out and
stated that they had proof that he was
indeed innocent and they have witnesses
that will testify that this never
happened he never assaulted his
girlfriend there's more on this that
we'll talk about in just a bit but this
is important to know because it's
important for the Kang Dynasty because
right now Jonathan Majors is Kang and
according to a recent report the Kang
Dynasty is actually about to start
filming in a report from variety they
state that the Kang Dynasty is set to
begin production in the spring of next
year now currently the Kang Dynasty is
set to release on May 2nd of 2025 so the
fact that they are about to begin
production next year is a great sign
that the Kang Dynasty won't be delayed
or pushed back because a lot of that has
been happening recently with Marvel
Studios as CU projects Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige and Disney CEO Bob
Iger have stated recently that they are
going to cut back on the quantity of
Disney Plus shows that they put out
stating that they are now going to be
focusing more on quality over quantity
we've also had some reports from
insiders stating that they're going to
cut back on movies as well and we've
already had some delays and we were
hoping that King Dynasty and Secret Wars
don't get delayed as well especially
with everything going on with Jonathan
Majors now like I said there has been
some new developments concerning his
case and again this is really important
because if things don't work out well
for Jonathan Majors then they're not
going to work out well for Marvel
Studios and they most likely will recast
which will definitely put a delay pretty
much in the entire MCU considering the
fact that Kang is the big bad of The
Saga that we're in right now the
Multiverse Saga however fangs are
looking up despite what we heard
yesterday yesterday in a report from
variety they stated that several other
women have went to the DA's office and
claimed that Jonathan Majors abused them
however the D.A office refused to
comment on the matter recently Jonathan
Majors was also fired by his management
and PR companies and unfortunately he
lost some movie deals yesterday however
despite all of this Jonathan Majors
attorney still says that he is innocent
and is the victim and that they have
irrevocable evidence that will prove
that he is innocent including some
videos and they have released
screenshots from the videos and it does
indeed line up with Jonathan Majors
aside of the story the original story
from Jonathan majors's girlfriend stated
that they were in a taxi or an Uber
where he abused her because she was
trying to look at his phone however
Jonathan Majors claimed that he simply
got out of the car and he never touched
her but in fact she was hitting him
trying to get his phone and he told the
driver to stop so he could get out and
leave then his girlfriend claimed that
he broke her finger scratched her behind
the ear causing her an injury however
they now have a video that proves very
differently here's the information that
we are now getting from the LA time
times and TMZ Who provided the photos
the article says Jonathan major says the
man who was driving him and his now
ex-girlfriend the Knight of their
alleged domestic incident will testify
the actor did not strike her and he
claims there's video proof she was not
injured when she went out to a club
after the altercation and these are the
photos that we're going to get to but
the article continues and States
Jonathan's attorney Priya Chaudhary
while docs Wednesday in Manhattan
informing the court the driver witnessed
what went down between Jonathan and the
woman back in March according to the
documents obtained by TMZ the driver saw
the woman assault Majors around 1am on
March 25th while she was attempting to
steal his phone further the Creed 3 star
says the driver will testify he never
struck the alleged victim in any way at
any time or even raised his voice majors
and his attorney also say the driver saw
her hitting scratching and attacking
Jonathan and that Jonathan asked the
driver to stop the car so he could
Escape her attack which he did here's
where things get interesting the woman
allegedly told police she suffered a
broken finger and a laceration behind
her ear during the altercation however
in the document that Jonathan majors's
lawyer provided they say they have proof
that that is a complete lie they say
they have hours of security videos
showing the woman went clubbing and got
drunk after Majors left her in the car
and she also texted him accusing him of
infidelity and threatening suicide and
they say that as far as what happened
when she went to the nightclub they have
screenshots of security videos showing
the woman freely using her right hand
which she claimed Jonathan Mages broke
her finger we can see that she's using
it in these photos here they say that in
these videos you can see her casually
push her hair behind her right ear reach
into her back several times sort through
credit cards handles her phone holds a
menu and easily holds a glass of
champagne TMZ says they say she was seen
partying pretty hard throwing back shots
and champagne with friends without any
visible sign of injury here's where
things get even more interesting they
say when her night out at the club was
over they claimed she showed up and
Majors his home at 3 23 am entered his
apartment and called him 32 times and
sent several angry jealous text messages
and Majors was not home when she arrived
Jonathan Major's lawyer says None of
these text messages accused Jonathan of
injuring her nor does she mention any
discomfort from alleged injuries they
then say that Majors got home at 11 13
a.m and found her unconscious and
half-naked on the floor of his walk-in
closet he also discovered she allegedly
threw up in his bed and told him she'd
taken a few sleeping tablets Majors then
called 9-1-1 and claimed when the
paramedics arrived the woman repeatedly
told them I don't know when asked what
happened in the document Jonathan Majors
lawyer claims body cam footage shows
police interviewing the woman and
clearly coaching her to say that Mr
Majors grabbed her by the throat Major's
attorney Chaudhry claims that the
alleged victim never made that claim to
anyone prior to the officer's Direction
so according to his lawyer the police
are the ones who told her to say that
Jonathan may just grabbed her by the
throat and they have video evidence of
this happening so they have video
evidence of his now ex-girlfriend
partying and using her hand what she
said was broken showing no signs of
physical pain or distress plus Jonathan
majors has the Uber driver as a witness
who is going to testify he never did
anything but in fact she assaulted him
plus they have three other people who
were outside when he got out of the car
who were going to testify in court as
well that he did nothing so if this is
all true what Jonathan Major's attorney
claims then this is good news for
Jonathan majors and he will probably be
innocent in this situation if they do in
fact have all of this evidence and this
is great news because this means Kang is
going to be unaffected in the MCU and
will most likely still be Jonathan
Majors providing that he is indeed
innocent and we've recently heard that
Marvel Studios has not talked about
replacing him yet at least not
officially and this is most likely due
to them wanting to wait to see what
happens and Jonathan majors of course
has talked to them and has probably told
them hey don't worry I got a lot of
evidence that proves that this did not
happen and that I'm innocent here so
right now Marvel Studios is playing the
waiting game waiting to see what happens
in court on May 8th like a lot of us but
the good news is if this is all true it
looks like Jonathan Majors is going to
be okay and the MCU unaffected and to
end it with some positive news Elizabeth
Olsen has recently talked about
returning to the MCU now of course she
is playing koi like all of the Marvel
actors do when asked if they're
returning but today when she was on The
Today Show she claimed that it's a hard
question for her to answer when asked
about if she's returning because she
feels her words are always Twisted every
time she answers it so she says no so my
no twist zone is yes I hope so but I
have no idea when I say that it's not
because as I have a loaded answer it's
because I say yes I hope so and I mean
it at face value they went on to ask
have you started filming and she said
absolutely not they asked have you seen
a script she said no and they ask has
there been a zoom call and Elizabeth
Olsen says there's no contract so she
didn't answer that directly however
Elizabeth Olsen has stated in the past
that her contracts were very short and
every time that they did a new contract
it was an extension however we have had
plenty of reports from very reliable
insiders claiming that we are indeed
going to be getting a Scarlet Witch solo
project and given how everything ended
with Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness there's no doubt that she is
definitely coming back to the MCU at
some point in time they just got a
lockdown her new contract which I'm
assuming is going to be coming pretty
soon but let us know what you think in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
MCU news you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof